j'ai jamais pensé que Mélenchon était un
homme de gauche j'ai toujours pensé que
Mélenchon était un transfuge aineux du
Parti socialiste qui s'est emparé de
l'extrême gauche française et qu'il a
vraiment essayé de de l'amocher et
malheureusement je pense qu'il a réussi
il a amené avec lui des des tas de gens
qui qui à mon avis ont rien à faire à
gauche qui terrifie tout le monde dès
qu'on dit un truc qui leur plaît pas
c'est les ordres de troll sur Instagram
c'est les machins et tout je me sens
bien avec les vieux propalestiniens
parce que moi j'ai fait des manifes
propalestiniennes le le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les manif
propalestiniennes elles son interdite
aux Juifs c'est si je mets un pied dans
une manif palestinienne je vais me faire
casser la gueule ça c'est un peu la
faute de Mélenchon en 2014 quand il y a
eu une manif qui s'est terminé par des
des synagogues dont on don on cassait la
porte et cetera et par des cris de mort
aux Juifs et quand on a demandé à
Mélenchon ce qu'il avait vu il a dit
j'ai rien vu j'ai rien entendu là il y a
eu un choix qui est pas joli qui à mon
avis lui a pas fait gagner de voix la
réalité de l'antisémitisme c'est quoi
c'est depuis depuis les les les
tragédies au Proche Orient il y a eu une
augmentation de plusieurs milliers de
pourc des actes antijuifs en France
c'est-à-dire que c'est c'est devenu on
on est devenu un pays pas safe pour les
Juifs c'est terrible et ça ça devrait
être une cause nationale on peut pas on
peut pas tolérer qu'en France quelqu'un
soit maltraité pour sa religion ou pour
son ethnie et ça on dirait que pour une
partie du camp de Mélenchon c'est pas un
sujet c'est un sujet avec lequel on peut
rigoler et et et ça a des conséquences
sur le quotidien des gens donc et en
plus de ça derrière ça selon moi il y a
un un racisme anti-arabe c'est-à-dire
qu'il a il y a un sentiment chez
Mélenchon et sa bande que ça va l'air à
un certain électorat mais c'est pas vrai
moi moi je suis un juif maghrébin moi je
vis avec des Maghrébins depuis toujours
et les Maghrébins que je que je
fréquente ça ne leur fait pas plaisir
quand on fait du mal aux Juifs et et je
moi j'aimerais une gauche qui parie sur
le fait que les citoyens français sont
faits pour s'entendre sont faits pour
s'aimer et et Mélenchon il fait pas ce
pari là Mélenchon il fait un truc qui
existait beaucoup en Algérie du temps de
nos grands-parents c'est on montait les
juifs et les Arabes les uns contre les
autres c'est le cadi qui recevait les
représentants des communautés et qui
jouit la petite guerre entre B ça se
terminé en pogrom et ça c'est pas beau
et je trouve que derrière ça il y a un
manque de respect pour les citoyens qui
mérite
mieux